are you um as like an independent artist
what are some of the things that you've
like uh learned over the last like four
or five years because I feel like when
you're independent sometimes you don't
have to like you don't have the luxury
of having a building behind you that
kind of already knows what not to do and
what to do you got to kind of like just
keep it moving when you when you yeah
you go through Growing Pains you got to
learn from your mistakes what are some
of the biggest things you've you've
learned so far the biggest thing that
well what I did this time that I came
home
um I try to rationalize my situation so
I tell myself all right there's no label
behind you no more
we're definitely trying to go back to
the pen for another 10. so what are we
gonna do you know what I'm saying right
I put myself in college
um for a year and I got myself into a
good field where I could generate enough
money to become my own label you know
what I'm saying what field was that um
electrical I do electrical oh [ __ ] yeah
hell yeah so so you're an electrician
yes sir hell yeah wow that's fire yeah
so um so yeah so I put myself to college
like I said because in my experience
before
um I felt like other people were
dictating the path of my music and how I
was going the direction I was going in
or when I could do this or right studio
time for that matter
so um
I didn't feel like I didn't feel like
begging though like like and I mean
begging like in the wrong way what I
mean is like I didn't want to put myself
in a vulnerable position and people be
looking at me like oh I'm A desperate
looking for help so
um I did my [ __ ] independently I funded
my own [ __ ] legitimately with with money
I was doing through my nine to fives and
long shifts I was pulling but at the
same time
um I have such a strong standing
reputation in the streets that it wasn't
hard for me to like get direct lines to
so and so so right right right
um I've dealt with people from all from
Crips to Bloods to everything on the
streets before so um it wasn't hard for
me to connect those dots so I just
worked with what I had you know what I'm
saying right I took advantage of the the
pros that I did have and the cons I just
try to evolve them into some that could
become an advantage also you feel what
I'm saying I feel like most people would
not uh
yeah I feel like having a practical
trade to to have to fund your dream yeah
is like something that most people
wouldn't glorify well well I did it the
other way before
and it and you landed in prison proper
reason I did over a decade you saw what
the yeah you saw with the downside yeah
yeah reality was like yeah you can be a
risk taker but the risk that we're
taking
um [ __ ] or long-lasting Consequences and
so I didn't you know and then you come
home to your family you gotta think like
after a decade my dad died you know my
brother-in-law died my grandma died my
cousin died like [ __ ] the house was
empty you feel me so
I came home to a family in shambles like
women that didn't have no mail in the
house there was no uncle that loved the
nieces there was no dad that loved their
kids there was no right older brother to
look over my sister you feel I'm saying
so with that I put my ego and my pride
to the side you feel I'm saying like I
felt like I had a bigger purpose you
know that's big man yeah I think like
two just for anybody watching like it's
okay to figure out well I think it's
[ __ ] way I think it's I think it's I
think that it's not okay not to do it
legitimately
because as a business let's say you're
doing real estate bro right and you're
buying houses to flip and [ __ ] of course
but you're doing enough of illegitimate
money one day they're gonna trace the
paper trail is going to come back to you
or or they're gonna catch you you feel
I'm saying you're just gonna get caught
out of the red light without the right
blinker on and it's a wrap you feel I'm
saying so the margin of error is [ __ ]
well yeah and like you you move around
stress the [ __ ] yeah well I did you know
I mean like the homie will tell you like
they they came for me they rated all my
pads I had to [ __ ] flee to Colorado
with an advance from the label I ended
up burning the label for their Advance
on that they never got to recoup up my
[ __ ] what type of which level Universal
okay [ __ ] so um so yeah so as a business
model it's not a good model too you know
what I mean to go and I know a lot of
people do it and I know it's glorified
um in this business but
I don't know bro I just can't do it
again you feel I'm saying I'm not ready
for that trip you know yeah no life's
too good more people should uh preach
what you're preaching man a lot of
people haven't been through what I've
been through that's why they don't
that's real if they knew better they
would they would say better you feel the
same but they don't